this must be like the uh the the glimpse
that you get at human psychology when
you're because i never
worked at buds you know i went through
it but i never saw it from the other
side yeah the glimpse at human
psychology of what
people are capable of and what breaks
them and and
that's got to be a yeah that's got to
leave a mark well
absolutely and you know you literally
learn a lot i mean
now you know you and i go through it but
you go through it it's different you're
experiencing it
when you have an opportunity to watch
class after class after class
you know i just remember you know the my
first hell week class
and um this is monday night of hell week
so they start off at sunday they've been
at it for about you know
22 hours 23 hours they're having their
evening meal
and the class you know outside
and there's a couple of students staying
behind in the chow hall
putting the chairs back into the table
now i thought that this was somewhat odd
so i'm sitting there with the
instructors having uh dinner i said so
what are these guys up to
yeah they're just waiting for the rest
of the class to leave so they can quit
um and and and it was true so you could
just say but
what it was is nobody ever
quit in the evolution everybody quit
before the evolution in anticipation
of what was gonna happen and just
now uh you can argue whether or not it
is the most demanding physical
course in in the military if it's not
it's close
all right so i won't argue with anybody
but i will tell you this
it is a far more psychological program
that it is a physical program because
it's designed to keep you
off foot uh and that the standards
are raised and raised and raised or the
the you're told that this is going to be
the evolution today
and then they change it but specifically
to that can you adjout to that can you
adjust to that
um uh so it really it is
most of the people who fit quit no i had
a
three and a half hour briefing today
down there with our teammates
an update on what the community's up to
and uh beef dressler
uh gave me the pitch and beef just took
over the center
on um on on friday and
they bring in uh close to 900
uh students a year to get 180 out
187 is his demand signal and 900
so it's still in spite of everything
that we've done
in preparation as you said you know when
you went through nobody knew when i went
through it was a trivial pursuit
question
you know but now these these guys are
prepared they know what he's doing
and they all i said to them today what
is the what is
it they they they self-select they raise
their hand
and they know we lose a couple from
academics
uh we lose some from pool comp but the
vast majority of it
this is not for me and when i used to
get the young men in the uh you know
now i was not an instructor and um and i
would get them all
after the instructors talked about hell
week i'd go in there
and i would just talk to these guys and
marcus talks about that in his book uh
i just look it's as simple as this guys
you know every one of you guys can make
it through
otherwise you wouldn't be here i mean
you've already been here now for several
weeks
if you're not going to make it you're
the one who decides you're not going to
make it
it's not going to be us at all and you
know
it's as simple as this guys i mean
necessarily the secret to life
is just don't quit just
don't quit i said don't doubt yourself
and um you know these guys they they
doubt themselves but it's
why am i here and i used to say when
they first came
what do you you know buds is not the
seal team
buds is buds it is where
why you need to spend 26 weeks to get
where you want to go
but don't even think for a second that
this is
a seal team but i will tell you this you
put up with this for 26 weeks
and you get to that seal team it will
make everything that you did here
worthwhile trust me i was down there a
little while ago and uh
you know i was walking around and there
was just with one of my friends
that works there and there's a hundred
helmets by the bell
100 helmets by the bell and
he says you know what i said i said
that's a lot of quitters this you know
whatever it was
two weeks in i said that's a lot of
quitters and he says you know what
every one of those guys is a stud
yeah a st and he's he's basically
referencing compared to us when we went
through
you know when i went through i thought
if you did a a pull-up workout where you
did
30 or 40 pull-ups that that was a pretty
good workout and you don't realize when
you get the buzz you're going to do
300 or 400 or 5 you just didn't know we
didn't know back then
but every one of these kids now they're
studs
physical studs but they still quit oh
yeah
yeah but the difference though
physically i would say
is um you know when i went through eric
olsen bill mcraven was two classes
behind me
um the way eric put it and i think this
is right
back then uh it depends on your parents
were
if you're gonna make it through buds
because it was endurance
everybody had to run forever and
everybody had to swim forever back then
so it was a different type of body type
now not everybody looks like you john
but
but as you know when you know when when
i took over the center
and these young men lined up next to the
pool in just their their swimsuits
it was a completely different physique
on those young men
uh but we were preparing them for
different things as opposed to
no long-range patrols you know no no no
10 to 12 days in the field
no 13-hour swims you're going to go to
the hindu kush
um and you're going to go to balad and
you're going to go to ramadi and you're
going to go to fallujah
and you've got to wear heavy equipment
and you've got to carry a lot of stuff
so it changed and i don't know what's
going to happen now that you know we're
we're changing and admiral howard
rightfully so is going back into
uh strategic competition great power
competition and putting the community
back
uh into a maritime focus get those
wetsuits ready boys
[Laughter]
absolutely uh did you you know it's
interesting
you know people always ask who's gonna
make it through who's gonna make it
through and i
would never put a bet on anybody one way
or the other
of who's going to make it through or not
i don't care where they came from what
their background was
i remember one of one of my commanding
officers uh
captain o'connell he had he he told this
story to me and i
i never forgot it he had he there was
some officer that was put in a package
to go to buds
and he said i've never backed anyone
before i've never i've never backed
anyone i've never said this guy's gonna
make and this guy had this pristine
record
he was an athlete this he was captain of
that he was all these things
he spoke two languages maybe even three
languages just to complete stuff and
finally
o'connell you know signs off his package
and says yeah take this guy to buds
and the freaking guy quit on him and he
said i will
never ever back anybody again
and to me that you know that was a
captain that had been in the teams
forever
and denied all these packages and even
with that level of discretion
you can't tell who's going to make it
and who's not going to make it oh
there's jim jim
yeah yeah no
no you really can't um and because you
really don't know what's going on behind
the eyes
so um we've got members who are
on the national teams um whether it's
the national swimming team that's you
know
these are very accomplished people
division one athletes
and but the other thing as well you get
some kid that comes out of high school
goes to boot camp
uh did intramural sports and he's
standing tall on graduation day
yeah that's me 100.
100 and i had a i had a i had an olympic
alternate gymnast in my buds class quit
and i had the ncaa
water polo team captain in my class
quit yeah and like like i was that guy
that i was an
average if not slightly below average
athlete in high school and
hey stuck it out they weren't gonna make
me quit that's the way it is yeah